and the Oscar goes to
Martin Scorsese
Martin
scores road to the
uh after he entered the Seminary and
then opted to channel his passions into
film
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
thank you thank you
thank you please please thank you thank
you could could you double check the
envelope
where's hi thank you so I mean I'm
overwhelmed um with this honor with the
academy and also the honor of being
presented by my old old friends we go
back 37 years I'm so moved and so moved
I
I I've got to thank Warner Brothers
Allen horn and and Dan and um and Jeff
and I've got to thank producers Brad
Graham Graham King and Mack Brown and my
old friend Joe Reedy have been working
for 20 years and Rick Ewan and John
lescher and Chris Donnelly and irie
Emmanuel and that crazy script by Bill
Monahan got me in all this trouble in
the first place and
um Andrew Law's original film uh from
Hong Kong the wonderful Asian Cinema and
Michael ballhouse on camera and Howard
Shaw's wonderful score and my old good
friend Thelma Schoonmaker
um
Ellen Lewis for her Casting and so much
of this belongs to the cast I can't tell
you Jack Nicholson for his courage and
his inspiration uh Leo DiCaprio six and
a half years work we've done together I
hope another 12 another 15. uh
Mark Wahlberg Matt Damon Alec Baldwin
Ray Winstone and Vera Farmiga and Marty
Sheen
um I just want to say too that so many
people over the years have been wishing
this for me so strangers you know I go I
went walking in the street people say
something to me I'll go in a doctor's
office they're going to whatever
elevators people saying I wish you
should Windows should win I'd go for an
x-rays they should win one and uh I'm
saying thank you and then like so
friends friends of mine over the years
and friends who are here tonight or
wishing this for me and my family I
thank you this is for you and I also
want to thank and I want to thank my
daughter Kathy who's here tonight who
worked on the film and Dominica and my
wife Ellen and our little Francesco
who's seven years old who's watching
right now Francesca stay up for another
10 minutes but then jump up and down and
make a lot of noise at the hotel
okay I'll see you in the morning thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]